council
i'm councillor catherine grandin
chairman of baber district council
and i will be carrying the meeting today
my first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please turn your telephones off
yes
so starting at the beginning
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs cold water is
also available in the breakout area
outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room by following the
fire exit signs
and meet on the ipswich town football
club training pitch
do not re-enter the building until
you're told it's safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting
you'll be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record
film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
before i move to the agenda
although i have already made my
declaration of acceptance of office
before the proper officer
i would like to restate it before
council
and take this opportunity of saying a
few words
[Applause]
i
catherine grandin
having been elected to the office of
chairman of the council
hereby declare that i take their office
upon myself and will duly and faithfully
fulfill the duties of it according to
the best of my judgment and ability
i undertake to be guided by the counts
by the suffolk local code of conduct in
the performance of my functions in that
office
i was not able to attend the annual
meeting but i particularly wanted to
make my declaration in front of you
fellow councillors officers and the
public
i regard the office as important and it
means a lot that you have voted me into
this position again
thank you councillors
first i want to offer a huge thanks and
congratulations
to councillor adrian osborne who has
done such an excellent job as baber
chairman
councillor osborne carries out his
duties with humor
thoughtfulness and professionalism
and i know he would have represented our
council at civic events with dignity
i regret that i was unable to offer
councillor osborne all the assistance i
would like to have proffered as his vice
but i know he accomplished a successful
job under sometimes difficult
circumstances following on from the
pandemic
and managed to hand over a very generous
check to his charity the kernel center
well done adrian
you're a hard act to follow
i have been privileged to sit in this
chair before
but my last term
it was rather different to this
i remember coming into endeavour house
in the middle of the lockdown to take my
first online full council meeting
now it all seems quite simple and almost
normal
but in 2020 it was rather surreal and
challenging experience as we did not
know if it was going to work
and it was a bit experimental
sometimes around 60 attendees
and of course the ball i was planning
was cancelled i had a reduced donation
to my charities
and representing the council
civic events
naturally ceased
one positive aspect was that i was able
to look forward to seeing the governance
team in person on council nights
that is a long time ago now
i'm so pleased that we are more or less
back to normal
and that councillor osborne was able to
employ a slightly more relaxed period as
chairman and i'm particularly grateful
to you my fellow councillors for giving
me this further opportunity as chair
and of course it gives me a perfect
excuse to buy new outfits
and get out there and proudly represent
the council
i'm also delighted that councillor derek
davis has been elected as my vice chair
i know we will work together very well
and he has already represented baber at
two civic events that i was unable to
attend
and provided me with other support
thank you derek
some may have noticed i have not been
very visible since last september
i would like to thank my fellow
councillors and officers who have in
their own and different ways
demonstrated their care and concern
my illness or certainly a shock to me
the support of my husband
rocky
friends happy community
councillors and officers kept me going
along with knowing i had an invitation
to royal garden party waiting in the
inbox
which brings me to my chosen charity
the switch hospital blossom appeal
like most people in the fortunate
position of accusing an appeal to
support
i'm choosing one with personal
connection
i have chosen the blossom appeal in part
to say thank you for the amazing work
the nhs does
but also to raise awareness of the
incredible service that switch hospital
breast team
offer to families across the county
i have first-hand experience of the
fantastic care
kindness and expertise offered
they have been and are a real source of
support
not just other women and men facing
breast cancer and their loved ones too
there are so many different aspects in
dealing with and fighting breast cancer
and this new breast
care center
will support women and men across faber
and wider suffolk by bringing all these
different elements of breast care under
one roof
i now realize that cancer affects so
many people
and it really is something that is
important to talk about
while i realize that some of you have
been very kind by not wanting to raise
the subject
i have made the decision not to avoid
talking about breast and other cancers
once we remove the taboo and
embarrassment we help to raise awareness
remind people to check themselves and
raise funds
the blossom appeal is raising funds for
the new dedicated
6.2 million breast care center ipswich
hospital
which will bring together the breast
clinic the imaging department and breast
screening for the first time while the
building work has already started
fundraising is still needed to complete
the work
the race is now on to raise the final
five hundred thousand pounds to ensure
every breast care patient will have the
best possible experience when they come
to the hospital
i'm planning at least one event which
you will hear about in due course
but you don't have to wait until then if
you've been keen to donate right away
but maybe wait until after the meeting
karen sayer has set up a just giving
page
and you simply search baber once you're
on the just giving site
thank you alistair for your early
donation
that was quick off the mark
[Applause]
finally
thank you all again for your
thoughtfulness while i have been neil
and for voting me as chairman
let's have a good positive final year of
this term
and get done all that we need to achieve
for our communities
as this is why we all stood as
councillors in 2019
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
can i move to the agenda now please
apologies for absence
thank you chair i have received
apologies for absence from cancers
carpendale creswell holt and newman
thank you
item two
declarations of interest by councillors
are there any declarations of interest
thank you
item three
paper bc 22
5
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on 22nd march 2022
for accuracy only should that be may
that should be may sorry
may
2022 for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
can i have a proposal please
counselor john osborne thank you
could i have a seconder please
councillor brynn haron thank you
can you raise your hands if you're
prepared to
fade the minutes please
support the minutes please
that's carried thank you
announcements now
from the chairman of the leader paper bc
22 6.
um i have a few words i wanted to say
um
first i refer you to paper bc226 for
noting
and i also wanted to mention that i was
at suffolk day the launch of suffolk day
today at franwii and castle
it was a really wonderful event and it
made you realize why we all love living
in this county
um it was very well attended lovely warm
weather
and you might have heard it on the radio
this morning
and it was also
um the event the same event was used
to award the suffolk medal which is the
highest award
that suffolk can give as a county
it was presented by the lord lieutenant
of suffolk and there were five
recipients today
so it was a really lovely event and
well represented
by other
[Music]
leaders and chairs in the county
and secondly i'd also like to draw
members attention to the fact that it's
armed forces day on thursday
and
as a hadley member
i'm very proud to say that the
one of the main events is happening on
thursday
in hadley
and i'd be delighted if as many of you
can come as possible
the armed forces day event takes place
at 4 30 in the marketplace and it gives
us a chance to also thank you
to our forces
and i'd love to see you in hadley if
you're able to come
i'd now like to move on and
invite councillor ward to make his
announcements
thank you council ward
thank you madam chairman it really is
good to see you back
it's been a busy month for me it started
on the first with an invitation to the
official opening of the first phase of
the new market in great yarmouth
the total project cost is 4.6 million
pounds partly funded by the council but
also with future high streets funds
support
the town is bustling and thriving having
had a bumper tourism season last season
last year due to travel restrictions and
expecting similar this summer
it is a bit galling though that they are
category one for the leveling up fund
which they hope to take advantage of
while we languish in category three
and on the evening of the first i was
invited to attend a major road accident
training exercise by the suffolk fire
and rescue service at ashington autos
this was their biggest training drill in
two decades and it was very interesting
to see the detail and complexity that
goes into
a response like this and also to see the
variety of equipment they can draw on to
help the victims and save lives
like many of you i attended several
jubilee events in my ward all of which
were very well attended and enjoyable
the weather threatened on the sunday but
it did remain dry if a little chilly
we had about 200 at the pulse of beacon
lightning on a warm thursday evening in
an idyllic location views across the
state by neyland where we could see
their beacon
on the 6th of june along with councillor
davis i was invited to the master
lowering ceremony at hms ganges
after several years of inactivity this
site is now on the way to being
redeveloped into a vibrant new community
with residential commercial retail and
leisure facilities
the master will be renovated and
returned to its position at the centre
of the site
later i watched the women's tour speed
through raiden in a slight drizzle at
lunchtime as i headed for shipley to see
ma farm vineyard with councillor holt
and michelle gordon
they have a great idea for a tourism
theme linking all the vineyards along
store valley this would sit well with
the artistic and heritage offerings at
baber
on thursday last week i intended the
preview of the what's next for sudbury
exhibition a lot of work was put into
this and it is gratifying to know that
it was so well attended over the three
days it was on
there were a total of 442 visitors
comprising members of the public
business representatives and county
district and town councillors
we've had a huge amount of positive
feedback
and the online survey for this is open
until the 18th of july
on friday evening last week i attended
the official opening of the subject
suddenly innovation lab in borumgate
this is part of our innovate local
initiative and offers businesses a
co-working space access to cutting-edge
technologies business support services
funding advice and network opportunities
in the heart of the town and it opened
businesses yesterday
next week i'll be attending the lga
annual conference in harrogate with
council macro
this is the first time this has been
held as a physical event since 2019 and
i am looking forward to seeing many of
my colleagues in person for the first
time in a long while
i'll provide a summary of what took
place on my return
i just want to take a few minutes and
let you know about the net zero carbon
tool kit
this was commissioned by local
authorities in oxfordshire funded by the
lga housing advisors program and has
been made available to be adapted and
shared by other local authorities
the suffolk climate change environment
and energy board has taken the
opportunity to publish it for the county
and earlier this year suffolk public
sector leaders group approved its
county-wide use
it has been created to make net zero
carbon new build and retrofit more
accessible for all building
professionals and is also relevant to
self-builders planning officers and
other housing professionals
although it can be used by homeowners it
is aimed at those who already have some
knowledge or experience of construction
the primary focus is on small to medium
scale housing projects but the
principles are generally applicable to
projects of any scale
it covers all stages of building design
and construction including maintenance
and operation
as our chairman has already mentioned
today is suffolk day and yet again we
have had the perfect midsummer's day for
it
this year it is particularly special
not just because we can enjoy it fully
for the first time in three years but
also because it is part of the ongoing
festival of suffolk the county's own
special celebration of her majesty's
platinum jubilee year
and finally i just want to mention two
of our slt who'll be leaving us soon
i know jan will be saying a few words
about gavin later but first i'd like to
say we will miss his professionalism and
hard work he's built a great team in
what is a very large and complex housing
service
yesterday's excellent all member
briefing
has given us all a great insight into
what he has achieved so thank you gavin
cass too will be sorely missed
the environment service is also
wide-ranging and complex made more so
with all the new work we're doing as we
face the climate change and biodiversity
challenges
her enthusiasm and humor have made
working with her a sheer delight
i think i speak on everyone's behalf is
saying that we will miss them both
greatly and wish them the very best for
their new challenges at ipswich borough
council and east suffolk council
thank you council award
as you said councillor osborne will be
mentioning a few words later but
councilman vasey and councillor gord
would like to say a few words
councilmembers would like to start
thank you
as you said earlier
and support in navigating the myriad
issues facing climate change and
biodiversity
she's been invaluable
helping bdc become a leader
in the country
for its achievements so i'd like you all
to join me with a very big vote of
thanks
[Applause]
that's the goal
thank you and i just felt that i had to
say something as well cass not well not
that i had to but i wanted to
as one of the new cabinet members
it was so reassuring for one of the
first people i spoke to to be cass
and i knew that you are the go-to person
in your words
and it reassured me it gave me the
confidence to just sort of to be sitting
here really so thank you very much
and
well our loss will be there again won't
it thank you yes
thank you
i'd like to add my thanks also to both
of you
uh let's proceed with the agenda now
um
item five to receive notifications of
petitions in accordance with council
procedure rules
thank you chair non-received
thank you
item six
questions by the public in accordance
with council procedure rules
i refer you to the question in the
tabled papers
i would like to invite mr riley to ask
his question
mr riley
thank you madam chairman and i'd like to
say how nice it is to appear before you
for the first time
it's good to see you catherine welcome
um and as always when one poses a
question here i reserve the right to ask
a supplementary
so my question
is a very simple one
and it refers to the corks lane
redevelopment
and he says as you can read
what possible justification is there
for a 9 000 pounds a month
to be spent every month on security for
the properties
thank you
yeah thank you for your question mr
riley the justification is simply is to
protect the premises
it has been necessary to have 24 7
security in operation at court's lane in
hadley due to the level of break-ins and
anti-social behavior that was occurring
at the vacant site
i'm sure you will agree that we couldn't
leave it unattended
the security presence on site has
reduced its activity
it has protected the listed buildings
from damage and vandalism and reduced
the impact of any antisocial behavior on
the immediate neighbours and community
security will be provided by our
contractors as part of the development
once the works commence on site in
august
thank you council award
mr riley i understand you have a
supplementary question
thank you madam chairman
well thank you for your answer it really
is as i expected
so
your answer by question
displays a complete ignorance
of what is needed to be leader of this
council
you dare
to bring forward
a multi-million pound proposal
with the prospect that it might
break even or incur a small loss
the first rule of stewardship
is that you must regard spending
residence moneys as if they were your
own council
please riley i appreciate your
interruption
it's a preamble to get to my question
could you please make it a short
question and relevant to your first
indeed it shall be there so there we are
so my supplementary question is this
having looked at this project
if baber is not making money out of the
project who is
council ward would you like to answer
that now
yeah i would actually um uh mr riley you
said that uh we'll break even or make a
slight loss we have never baber has
never said that the only person who said
that actually perversely is uh
council dawson on the radio uh just over
a week ago
i have always said this council has
always said we would break even or make
a profit
the fact that you attributed that to me
on the radio was actually slanderous but
we won't go there
um so
break even or make a profit
more likely older place more likely to
make a profit so
um no interruptions
no interruptions thank you
if you're going to interrupt i'll have
to have you removed from the room please
[Music]
can you not interrupt please
so we are redeveloping the site we will
break even or make a profit more likely
the latter
it's a project which has been delayed
unfortunately but we're finally in
position to make
progress with it and indeed that'll
allow me
to
honour a commitment that i and my
colleagues opposite made in our
manifesto in 2019.
thank you council award
we'll move on to the next item on the
agenda item seven
please
can i hear what it is please
yes i would like an apology from
both councillor ward and councillor
arthi for laughing at the member of
public thank you
i
i can't say i noticed such laughter
really this has got nothing to do with
being a point of order anyway
um
we can look at the films uh at a later
stage and if an apology is deemed
necessary
we will
look at the films first okay thank you
item seven questions by councillors in
accordance with council procedure rules
non-received chair
thank you
item eight
paper bc 22 7
the development of the housing revenue
account business plan
i would like to invite councillor jan
osborne to introduce paper bc 22 7.
thank you councillor osborne
thank you madam chairman and welcome
back also it's nice to see you up there
i am pleased to introduce report bc 22
7.
typically a housing revenue account
business plan sets out the priorities
plans and actions for council housing
over the next 30 years
our hra business plan was last revised
in may 2017
therefore it is pertinent that after
five years a fundamental review of the
plan and its priorities take place
the purpose of such plans is to show
that we can maintain our existing
housing assets and deliver a quality
customer focused service
as well as improve homes and
neighborhoods while supporting and
endeavoring to achieve the visions of
the organization's key strategies
an effective hra business plan has
become even more crucial since central
government announced the reform of the
rules governing local authority housing
finance and the introduction of the
self-financing system a decade ago
members may recall that last year
they were invited and consulted on what
they saw were the emerging priorities
when developing the hra business plan
this included surveys and a focus group
whilst in january this year a paper was
presented to four council on the
progress being made to develop this plan
and what the guiding principles of the
plan would be
then in may we held an all member
briefing on the hra business plan for
which we have produced the frequently
asked questions in response to members
questions
and yesterday this was followed by an
excellent briefing on the whole of the
housing service which was very well
attended by members
i am pleased to promote the key aims of
the plan which include
increasing the stock of social housing
owned by the hra through an ambitious
development program including an average
up to 65 new homes each year for the
next six years
developing new homes that are built to
the highest standard
contributing to the council's effort to
ensure carbon neutrality
including an affordable housing strategy
a new build design guide and technical
specification
improving the quality of existing homes
and communal areas and reduce the carbon
footprint of existing council homes
through investment in assets community
led regeneration and working with
communities and individuals
including the investment of more than 16
million pounds to ensure every home
meets epc c standard by 2030
ensuring that our homes and the
management of them maintain and improve
wellbeing outcomes for individuals
families and communities alongside other
council services and partners
making sure the hra business plan
continues to continuously remain
financially viable and sustainable
it is vital that the hra has a balanced
financial plan that repays its debt
within a reasonable period of time
therefore we can currently afford to
build 65 new homes for each of the next
six years
future iterations of the hra business
plan and reviews in subsequent years
will determine the number that the
council can then afford to build in year
7 8 and onwards
the exact number that we can build in
year 7 and onwards will be dependent on
continuously reviewing the hra finances
nearer that time on an annual basis and
accounting for changes that cannot be
predicted today
for example further rises and falls in
income and expenditure
the plan is focused on seven main
priorities which are
tackling and adapting to climate change
developing new council housing investing
in our current homes
involving our tenants in the running of
the housing services
improving the services that we provide
to our tenants
improving the neighborhoods that we
manage and implementing digital
transformation
inevitably there will be challenges
ahead including maximizing our income
which by
2025-26 will be as much as 21. 21.6
million per year as well as being
efficient and delivering value for money
in our expenditure which by 2526 will
include having invested more than 17
million on repairs to council homes more
than 30 million on capital improvements
to existing homes more than 45 million
on investing in new homes as well as 26
million of additional borrowing
today you have the report and final
version of the plan in front of you
which provides understanding of the
revised hra business plan and its aims
and objectives prior to it being
presented to cabinet in july for
approval
councillors although a recommendation to
note the approach to developing the hra
business plan has been included in the
covering report before you today
i will not be moving that recommendation
this is because the monitoring officer
has clarified that it is not necessary
to vote on a motion to simply note
the council is being asked tonight to
comment on the hra business plan for 22
to 2052
these comments will be considered by the
cabinet before we take a decision to
approve
the final version of the plan in july
thank you madam chairman with your
permission before i sit down
i'd like to say a few words about our
assistant director of housing gavin fisk
as this will be his last full council
meeting before he leaves for pastors new
in july
gavin has now been with the council for
many years and is homegrown
in that time
we have all grown to admire and respect
his devotion to his role including that
to our residents and the support he has
always given to his team and to members
he's always been ahead of the game
and proactive in his responses
his team will miss him
members will miss him
and i will certainly miss him
so thank you gavin and all the best in
your new role thank you
[Applause]
thank you councillor osborne
i'll just read out the recommendation
and then i'll call for questions and
comments
so the recommendation is
oh
so we're just noting it so um
i'd like to
uh ask the room if there are any ask
council if you have any questions or
comments counselor beer
thank you madam chairman yes i have a
question for the independent cabinet
member for harrison jan
um
when will we deliver
you've stayed on pages 24 paragraph 4.8
what will our plans deliver
page 26
4.26 improve the existing car parking
provisions
in our areas
page 31 acknowledges 81 of residents are
unhappy
pages 34 and 69
where is the word priorities
for car park and reaction and when will
you deliver something
thank you
that's rules for yeah thank you
councillor beer for your uh question we
are actually already delivering on
parking um
there is no easy solution you know it is
a we've got a real problem where a lot
of our houses are 76 60 70s built
people didn't even have a car let alone
one car or two cars cars so
in regards to parking there is no easy
solution but it is being looked at
we need to work with suffolk county
council so might be probably coming to
you for some solutions as well on that
one and some finance possibly as well
so we are moving on that one a lot of
work is taking place behind the scenes
to address that already we've been um
issuing um letters to people where
they're parking on grass verges that
they shouldn't have been parking on
to um make sure that they remove their
car otherwise we take enforcement notice
so that is happening we've also got a
little tag that we've ordered we haven't
got them yet that we're going to put on
cars where they're
inappropriately parked so we can do that
as well so we are delivering on that
in regards to
also again on parking as you know we've
been doing a garage review
which
has been taken quite some time because
of cold it was put on the back burner
however it would appear that um some of
the sites that we thought were suitable
for future development actually aren't
going to be suitable for future
development they're not going to be
financially viable but there'll be a
report on that coming to cabinet in
september with much more details on that
but what we're thinking of is there
again with parking it would be more
appropriate in some cases to
try and remove the garages and provide
extra parking
so there is a lot of work going on in
regards to anti-social behaviour if
which is safer neighborhoods and all
these priorities they're all uh
identified as a priority within the uh
business the hra business plan a lot of
work is going on with antisocial
behaviour again as great partnership
working with the police we never used to
have such great partnership working but
we've now got that we suffer county
council there's a lot of work going on
there in regards to anti-social behavior
mental health trust we're working with
them as well so again in the background
there's a lot of work going on now i'm
always happy to have sit down and have
meetings with counsellors
answer to emails if you want to know the
work that's being done but i don't want
to bombard you with information of all
the work that's being gone i'm kept
really busy officers are kept really
busy but if you want meetings i'm more
than happy to do that so i can show you
the progress that we're making thank you
madam chairman
yes okay council bears
related to those last question very
quickly related to that uh well i would
appreciate much more information from
you keeping us informed um on these
parking issues as you know i've been on
about it to you and others for years and
so as other people
and you haven't been keeping us all
informed you may be doing all this
behind the scenes but we need to know
what's happening in our areas thank you
thank you
councillor hinton you're next
yep
sorry
thank you madam chairman a couple of
quick points uh firstly on page 35 of
the council papers it talks about
financial assumptions rents increasing
by 4.1 percent in april 2022
or we know there was a bit of a mix-up
there and it wasn't april that uh things
were happening but further down the page
it talks about scenario five effects for
one year rent freeze in 2223
which is it have we got a rent freeze or
have we not
that was the first question and the
second one refers to a bit late later on
there is no within the environmental
measures etc etc there is no mention of
solar panels which obviously will
generate the electricity to help offset
the costs of these
air source heat pumps that are proposed
and also
there's nothing about
the location of where these council
houses are going to be built because we
know as being a member from a rural area
we get a lot of houses built in rural
areas with no
services and facilities to support them
and obviously people who want affordable
housing from us are probably more in
need of that support than anybody else i
have several other small points but
rather than take up all the time here i
will send an email across to the housing
team and i'm sure they can answer them
thank you councillor hinton
councillor would you like to answer
those yeah first of all if i can just
come back on councillor beer's last
comment we actually had an excellent
briefing yesterday that gave a real
thorough update on what we've done over
the last 12 months and where we're going
for the next 12 months so that for any
members that didn't attend that briefing
it was recorded so i would advise you to
sit and listen to it it was a very very
comprehensive uh presentation and i can
see members around me are shaking their
heads they were really nodding their
heads rather they were very pleased with
that presentation um on to respond to um
counselor hinton on the rent freeze that
he refers to we don't know
to be honest with the legislation we we
have a feeling that the government may
do a rent freeze they may even do a rent
reduction because the cost of living
crisis we don't know so we need to watch
this space but that's all been taken
account of in the hra i don't know if
gavin would like to
respond to that one in more detail
thank you chair thank you uh councillor
osborne um
i'm sure i get the chance to speak
several times this evening in response
to questions but just before
i respond to that question um thank you
for the kind comments uh earlier um they
were very kind 16 years working for
for baber and then baker mid-suffolk has
organizations
and i've seen the organizations both
organizations evolve improve
and and develop
so i know babe and mid-suffolk are
identified as fantastic organizations uh
by uh current workforce uh by people i
talk to in the sector uh a
wide range of people and that's truly
down to the forward thinking uh and
initiative approach that you as members
have uh have delivered so um just if i
don't get the opportunity if i can just
take this opportunity to wish every
member every officer and every resident
every success in the future
in response to the question um from
council hinton
solar pv yes is going to be
a key conduit for
improving the energy performance of
existing homes
it's testament to to members that in
2014 2015 you made the decision to
invest in solar pv
some seven eight years ago and installed
on more than two thousand council houses
uh that will progress and you will see
additional solar pv installed in future
years um in relation to the rent freeze
i apologize um in terms of the the
papers there is some confusion uh this
is because some of the scenario work
that we were doing we were doing last
year uh and then we brought it forward
and was doing this year so for example
if you turn or you looked at page 43
that scenario scenario two
was looking at a potential rent freeze
next year 23 24
so it looks at what the impact of any
rent freezes of course it's the
decision of the council in terms of
february next year what what decision is
made in terms of
of rents
and then just to feed back on some of
the other points made already if i can
and just build on what council osborne
has already said
we've got neighborhood strategy coming
forward uh over the next six months we
expect that to set uh set the direction
of travel for how our states will be
managed uh we've already developed a
neighborhood team in the recent uh
in recent years
and they're doing fantastic work
inspecting our estates
and ensuring that they're up to
standards we have a new tenant
engagement strategy coming forward in
october this year
we've begun to introduce estate
walkabouts there was one
last week by officers to look at
problems raised by
concerned residents
we have an action plan that we've
developed in recent weeks in response to
tenant survey results
that you see in the report in front of
you
so there is lots of work going on in
touch in tune is a is a
an all
member
or staff briefing that we produce at
least on a monthly basis
so i will make sure that officers are
feeding in and reporting on
and promoting some of that positive work
in those uh in those channels as and
when appropriate so thank you
thank you
council marvel you had a question
thank you
councillor busby you were next did you
have a question
okay thank you
councillor ward i had you down for a
question or
have you not got a question now
uh no uh thanks em um just just a few
things um
i'm pleased that uh we've had some
clarity on the
um likely renting increases and the
possibility of
a freeze at some point because again on
page 35 it does talk about
uh rent increases of cpi plus one
percent over the next few years and we
all know cpi is currently 11
so
annual rent increases the 12 are going
to be quite
significant and unbearable for most
people
the other thing i just wanted to mention
we talked about building 65 houses a
year for the next five or six years
uh clearly
we've got to go beyond that because
we've got
numbers for social and affordable
housing outlined in the joint local plan
over the 18-year period of the joint
local plan
and that will require us another
registered providers to deliver a lot
more than the nato over the period so
clearly we're going to need to
to review that after the five years and
build beyond that
but the last point i just wanted to
mention
the um
the plan talks about the the building
safety bill um that received royal
assent in in april it's now the the
building safety act i know that's a
slightly pedantic point but i think we
probably need to update that the other
the other thing also that um we really
need to refer to to make sure that the
plan does address will be the
implications of the social housing
regulation bill which is is going to
come before parliament soon
so uh that's all ma'am chairman thanks
thank you council ward answer us did you
have a question
nobody can make comments as well it's
questions and comments
questions and comments
sorry counselor airs i believe you oh
i'm down as the wrong person no
counselor councillors you're next
to the report
i'm a little concerned
particularly with the people in my ward
and page 27
on the digital transformation
particularly 0.434
about supporting tenants with skills and
tools to embrace the digital methods
and and all the stuff that will go to
help you however 20 of these people
cannot use a computer or a laptop
and that's one need that we really need
to address so how are we going to do
that east suffolk provided
some little um
laptop things for them so i just
wondered what what are we going to do
for those really important 20 of
residents thank you
thank you councillor yeah thank you
councillor yeah obviously as we have
done all the way through
uh we will continue to support those
residents that don't have access
to uh to a pc it's just that the um use
of um
the system um is digital transformation
is actually taking off and a high
percentage of people now use it for
example benefit claimants i think it's
98 of benefit benefit claims are done
online so there is a huge take-up for it
so that's why we have to be prepared to
be able to move forward with it but of
course that percentage that you've
quoted councillor ayers of course will
continue to support them in the same way
that we have done previously so we won't
be taking that choice away from them
we're just preparing so that we're ready
planned implant things in place so that
we can meet the demands and the
challenges that's coming forward
thank you very much
yes a lot of those that maybe do go
online is because they're queuing in the
library because we only have the um
access point open for ten and a half
hours a week which is a problem in
sudbury
and so they are maybe going online but
with the help of other people or going
into the library so i don't think
they're doing it independently thank you
yes thank you
oh no sorry um
it's it's our officer who's going to
talk first
sorry sorry chair um i just wanted to to
just add to councillor osborne's comment
and we are embarking on digital skills
training for
some of our tenants
digital skills training in our shelter
schemes will commence within the next
month and that's in partnership with sam
lake
and colleagues
outside of the organization so
we're trialing digital skills training
within amongst our sheltered housing
residents we've also been talking about
supporting some of those that are moving
into temporary accommodation
without those skills to enable them uh
to develop um as they move through
temporary accommodation and into their
own housing so
we'll be able to see some of the results
of that in the forthcoming months
um i've got a comment
um on
pencil award thank you thank you madam
chairman um you say on page i didn't put
glasses on
unfortunately it's getting old as you
say on page 26 4.23 we'll learn from
every complaint that we get
well i think that's a bit of a joke
because we certainly don't
page 31 item nine consultation paragraph
line seven you say that 87 of tenants
are unhappy with us
that's because we've failed to deliver
start in their values
appendix say page 58 this is a good one
reducing grass cutting
where you'll get no brony points to that
the public out there already fix the
poor servers you're delivering and then
you you say you want to cut up yet again
page 63
improvements and remodeling of our
estates when we said that's underway
page 64.
hold us to account
well somebody should be taking
responsibility and being held to account
for not delivering
page six oh sorry page 77 i think that
there is only one mention about
antisocial behavior in a one line
and i hope that you include
the the neighbors as victims because
they're certainly the ones that suffer
who live near the anti-social behavior
that goes on
members you don't seem to understand
that our tenants will not give up their
cars
what they need us to do is to deliver
car parking spaces on our estates
as you know i've been campaigning for
seven years along with others you have
done nothing but talk talk and more
talking there's no action going on
our residents
park in unofficial spaces near their
homes
at the moment for safety reasons also
residents have to drive to work to
schools
to shops leisure centres the post office
hospitals and doctors surgeries
mind you the new doctor surgery in
sudbury i hear a rumor that the doctors
can't get financial support so let's
hope that means that the great corner
doctor surgery will remain open so my
residents in coronado can continue to
walk to the corner surgery
there that should please you my green
colleagues thank you very much
thank you councillor osborne
i won't answer all those uh because i
think some of them had answered before
regards to the um grass cutting my
colleagues here most probably be able to
answer that better than me but in the
biodiversity plan we make it very clear
that we will do less grass cutting and
i'm getting calls from residents that
are actually
saying well done for the what you're
doing with the grass cutting because
what they're doing is where there's an
area of wild flowers or wild plants
instead of cutting that down and just
leaving it cutting it and leaving it
they've actually been putting foot past
through
to leave it and it looks really nice
sorry council of beer but there's a
mixed view on this one and that's that's
the view of that one in regards to the
delivery you've referring again and i
will refer you back to the presentation
that we did given yesterday where it was
very clear the housing service have
delivered a lot over the last 12 months
and where they're planning to go over
the next 12 months so i really would
suggest you you have a look at that
recording because it will answer a lot
of questions that you've just referred
to
thank you councillor osborne
councillor melanie barrett
um
council osborne you you talk about
financial sustainability earlier um
but i am concerned about the proposal
and the number of new council-owned
houses uh increasing each year by 65 in
fact
john ward has just mentioned a a higher
figure than that
um this is an 18 increase
so the impact of that will be
increased maintenance costs in increased
management costs
by 18
i don't know if that's
that's already in in the figure there
just a moment can you confirm that
measures available to
councils to ask residents to renew their
tenancy agreement
after the five years
tenancy agreement has lapsed for certain
of your attendance um is um to better
uh
to be better able to offer council
properties to those in the priority
category need
is this actually used by this council to
to good effect so that you don't always
have to increase
your properties year on year you have
got some churn so you can always
address those in on the waiting list
thank you councillor barrett would you
like to answer that council i was born
yeah thank you thank you i'm rather
surprised that a councillor isn't
welcome in the fact that we're going to
build or acquire
65 and possibly more new homes for
people that are in desperate need of a
roof over their head i find that rather
strange
the reason for the maintenance now they
won't cost us much more on maintenance
the maintenance costs are very high
because as i said previously to council
of beer's question was that we have a
high proportion of properties that are
60s 70s if you built them now they've
never been allowed to be built let's be
honest and they need an awful lot of
maintenance done to them with new
properties if they're built in the right
way and that's where the design comes
into its own hopefully that will reduce
the maintenance costs but all that has
been taken into account and as we've
said that's over the five-year period
with 65 per year we will review it again
in five years so we'll look at those
maintenance costs to see if they are
increasing but i think it's good news
don't you that we're going to be
building 65 plus more homes per year
thank you councillor dawson
um yes if i just asked um council
osborne i should go i was going to ask
you firstly
um it might be released
sorry can i just sorry councillor dawson
there was a question on the tenancy
agreement that perhaps i could ask our
gavin to come in and answer please
sorry council
okay gavin
sorry i'll come back to you in a moment
councillor dawson
thank you chair and council marifer for
the question um just in relation to i
think what you were describing with
fixed term tenancies where a tenant may
have a tenancy for a time limit period
uh perhaps five years um
we baby labour and soviet district
councils have never adopted
such a policy to provide fixed term
tenancies um many social housing
providers that have adopted fixed term
tenancies uh since the government uh
gave gave permission have actually moved
away from it and moved back to secure
tenancies i think one of the challenges
is that that fundamentally um
there's not a significant change in a
person's lifestyle and and um
and and abilities to to move from social
housing uh within five years uh so
secure tendencies are what we uh what we
provide and that gives any tenant the
opportunity to
maintain stay in that property uh for
for their lifetime um subject to
obviously not breaching the the terms of
the tenancy um
but certainly making best use of our
stock and having conversations with
tenants um where they may be uh
overcrowding or under occupying the
property i think um is a practical uh
step that we we want to take going
forward
so just in regards to that and just in
terms of an earlier point um in relation
to management and maintaining complaints
we actually have a complaint task force
in the housing service which
reviews every complaint and issues a
quarterly report
on
the performance of the housing service
in relation to complaints so how many
complaints of what type what lessons
have we learned what have we changed in
response so i'm happy if members
aren't aware of that report to ensure
that that's
shared more broadly on a quarterly basis
because you'll see that the improvements
are being made to the service as a
direct result of complaints
thank you
thank you councillor dawson can i just
finish my point please
following up on what's just said okay
yes
um that's interesting to hear um
there is um there is a um inherited
rights i think with the tenancy um of
council properties
um
would it not be a halfway house to adopt
uh a measure so that those tendencies
are handed back to the council at that
point
um
if you aren't going to adopt the the um
the available um
five-year tenancy fixed term tendencies
that you you talk about
can i i mean because i understand that
people can um
pass their tendencies onto their
children which um ties up that tendency
for
so many years and prevents
any anyone in perhaps greater need
having that that's a property
thank you councillor
and uh chair um
yes what you're describing is a
succession so
uh every council tenant has the right to
uh legally a succession uh within their
their tenancy only one uh should i add
um in terms of of those rights
typically
when a tenancy is succeeded we will work
with that individual it's a succession
to
to the tenancy not to the property so
for example uh there are cases where
maybe
one one single son or daughter is
succeeding to a free bedroom house
that's totally uh nonsensical for for
them to stay there for for so many
reasons nonetheless none least that the
cost of maintaining that property so
we'll work with those individuals to
find them uh more suitable accommodation
uh appropriate to their needs i know
when succession occurs and when sadly uh
individuals are found in this position
it can cause
a lot of concern and i know in terms of
my mail bag
many of them are fire members who are
concerned about the individuals so we we
really take a really positive proactive
approach supporting those individuals uh
providing a level of hand-holding
particularly in in response to to the
fact that they've just
lost a and suffered a bereavement
but we maximize that um what we can't
prevent and legally there can only be
one succession so there can't be
multiple successions and in those
circumstances we'd look to to recover
the property um that that said if a
person's in need of housing obviously
they would need to follow the route
through housing solutions uh in in
regards to alternative accommodation
thank you gavin
councillor dawson
um yes sorry i've got a few questions
actually
um the first one is to councillor
osborne um
at the bottom of page 44 uh
your report talks about the introduction
of additional zero carbon works scenario
one exposes the limits of the hra
council
and then you go on to say when any
freeze of rent scenario two would
require the authority to borrow more to
compensate for this loss of income
um and then at present the authority
struggles to deliver new homes
and zero carbon investment but on the
other hand you're talking about
building 65 homes
so that was the first part of the
question
um if you could provide some clarity on
that because it's just really very
confusing what you're saying what's in
the report
and the second one is
we've talked about a freeze of rents in
222-23
and earlier in your report on page 38
there's a dip in the balances in the
capital programme
for 2022-23
um is that because you're introducing
service charges and applying rent
flexibility i'm not quite sure if
they're related or not
what you're trying to say here exactly
yes gavin could you answer that please
exactly thank you councillor dawson um
i'll try and interpret uh what you're
saying if i've got it wrong then please
correct me and
point me in the right direction um in
regards to the scenarios the the first
scenario that is in the document um was
in relation to the investment to bring
all of our social housing up to um a
zero carbon uh standard so in addition
to meeting epcc by 2030 which has been
built into the baseline of the plan and
and will cost the council in excess of
the 15 million plus this was looking at
retrofit measures that would take us to
zero carbon
and you'll see at the start of the
scenario i think it describes
a retrofit cost of 24k
per property so
in excess of
uh 90 91 million pounds to bring all
properties up to that standard um that's
where there's there's challenges in
terms of of the plan and being able to
invest that level of uh investment in in
homes and naturally in regards to
existing council housing there will be
many homes that we can just never reach
that that zero carbon measure because it
would cost more uh in in terms of uh
cost and and carbon to
to remove it than and to
to reach that level and that's where
we'll need to flex and change uh and
adapt our approach in terms of the type
of accommodation type of property and
whether or not it's a property that we
we might want to look to to dispose of
or or
use in an alternative way
so
that's um that was the scenario in
regards to that and then then everything
else that we are trying to to deliver uh
so clearly there's a challenge there
what i would add is that when developing
the business plan and developing these
scenarios what we haven't assumed is any
additional grant government grant or
or ability to to access things like the
social housing decarbonisation fund
clearly those funds are out there and
the work that we've done with the energy
saving trust puts us in a really good
position to apply for those funds going
forward
but clearly um it's a lottery as to
whether or not we'll be successful and
we can account for a level of grant per
property uh because that would be non
nonsensical and and
not financially savvy so whilst it it
really struggles uh in terms of the
business plan to provide that um there
is the opportunity to look at new
funding as and when it becomes available
and that might reduce our dependency in
terms of that contribution of 90 plus
million
to reach that level but clearly we'll
continue to monitor the stock
on a regular basis
and then regarding service charging so
there is a paper coming to cabinet in
july uh that talks about um a rent and
service charge policy and the potential
introduction of um additional service
charges to improve the the standards of
accommodation and the environment around
uh around those homes for residents so
that policy will be coming forward
that's a decision for cabinet to make
if the decision is to start to begin to
introduce more service charging then
you'll see that in terms of future years
and future income lines
in terms of where
where that might be be recovered for
services that are currently costing at
the hra
in terms of rent flexibility rent
flexibility is a means of housing
revenue accounts generating
more income up to 105
of of of income
but in the rent and service charge
policy that's coming forward in july
the proposal is that we won't use rent
flexibility uh as a blanket tool to
generate more income
it is potentially something that you as
members and as a camp uh council might
want to consider uh in the future but i
think um our conversations my
conversations with the portfolio alter
for housing rent flexibility and a
blanket policy to to use rent
flexibility just wouldn't be appropriate
in in today's world particularly with
the cost of living crisis so maybe
something that could be used in the
future to generate more income
wow
yes if i could come back then so am i
correct and understanding that this is
being introduced to service charges
and
it does say here quite clearly it when
it will we'll we will we would be
appropriate we can deliver them but are
we doing that because we're doing
are we doing the rent freeze and
therefore introducing this policy and
that's why we're giving a rent freeze
so
the rent freeze was just
a scenario um you may recall and i don't
have the numbers in front of me but when
we sat in this room in in february uh
debating uh any rent increase for for
this financial year that there was a
table and it's the cumulative effect of
uh no rent increase or any rent freeze
because it's not just the the cost to to
the hra for that one year it's the
accumulative effect in in future years
and that clearly um does have an impact
on the overall plan um when you're
looking at income and expenditure over
over 30 years so um that's a decision to
be made in the future we just looked at
a scenario around
rent freeze to see what impact it had on
on on the business plan we're not
proposing any rent freeze we're just
testing the plan in terms of of what
it might do
thank you council mccraw
that's okay i'll use this one
my apologies madam chair thank you very
much um i have a mixture of questions
and a possible comment so i'd like to
ask gavin fisk if you can just help me
here the beginning of the paper states
that this is a development of the hra
business plan adopted in 2017 um five
years ago so um and it's a if you like
an update and an adaptation can i ask if
the fundamental drive of this is and its
overarching aims are similar to that one
adopted by the council in 2017.
so i would personally say no i wasn't uh
i wasn't involved in in the development
of the the previous hra business plan it
was obviously produced
more than five years ago and i think the
the situation that the council found
itself in at that time it was about
trying to save money and create
efficiencies we were facing a period of
prolonged
rent freeze and clearly that was having
significant impact on the plan i think
the plan that you have in front of you
today
is about ambition and it is about
development in terms of that the housing
service building on sound foundations i
hope that have been built over the last
five years but then really taking that
hre business plan forward 65 new homes
every year for the next six six years is
hugely ambitious uh for for the
authority and should be uh should be
well received
thank you that's very helpful because i
think it's important to establish that
there are differences and i'm probably
going to ask councillor osborne to
provide a little bit of a summary of
those differences now from my
recollection and i'm only going on my
recollection at the time i'm 2017 i was
relatively near the council but not that
new um and we didn't have this ambition
we didn't have a developed plan now what
we're talking about here today is an hra
plan it's going on to the year 2052
and we've had a lot of comment on minor
bits and pieces here and there which
obviously we deal with all the time
grass cutting parking those are dealt
with in other policy areas they're not
necessarily part of an hra which is a
high level overarching document to
provide us with
a structure um to fulfill the ambitions
that we have
and nitpicking and i have to say that's
all i seem to have heard today
about every single aspect well we did
every hri does deal with a lot i object
to madam chairman
can you sit down
because i think it's an appropriate one
um
nitpicking is something that doesn't
actually help us
throw any light on this subject the hra
is an important thing there is ambition
being described here i would draw
members attention to the
infographic and um this i would also
draw to the attention of the general
public i'm trying to find the page if
somebody
can
get my
screen to come down it's in green
um and it contains some useful bits and
pieces in 2017
none of the things on that infographic
would have been true
they are now
because we're actually doing something
20 or 30 years this council didn't build
any houses the hra could have been
described as moribund i know councillor
hurun will tell me that
a certain government made us buy back
our own properties i know it's something
you still find rather annoying i can
understand why
however we're not going to get you
started bryn
that infographic you can find in green
on page 49. i think that is the sort of
thing that describes the content of this
paper and frankly arguing around the
houses no pun intended
isn't getting us anywhere
this is a high level document all these
things are contained within it
as they are in each of the individual
policies that actually deal with the
questions being raised
from the other side so i'd like to
suggest that perhaps we could move to
just approving this uh or at least
approving that it go forward to cabinet
who will make the final decision
we have a couple more uh councillors who
wish to have questions or comments
uh councillor bosby
i'll be very short
look this is very ambitious and
challenging plan
there are a lot of competing demands
on our funds increasing houses means
increasing rents which means we have
more money to help achieve
our objectives hopefully in the first
few years before building new houses we
won't be spending a huge amount of money
on the maintenance of those houses so
that in fact should help us
look there's
i think alistair's put it right there's
a
there's a lot of detail that's got to go
into this um
and we can't expect jan and her team to
come up with all the answers
we should be contributing as much as
anybody to the problems in our
particular areas i mean look peter
you've been a counsellor for what i
don't know 30 years possibly and
we want answers from you
not just tell us the problems tell us
some of the solutions as well
now that's just going to tell me the
problems again i want the solutions
and we're all responsible for coming up
with these ideas don't just rely on one
person
thank you councillor jameson
thank you madam chair uh it's going to
make a comment about retrofitting
um now i understand retrofitting working
in isolation
is is extremely expensive i've spoken to
gavin before about the lewis model
uh lewis council of poland resources
with six other councils in their area
and together they've managed to pull a
fund at a billion pound fund
which is allowing them to tackle 40 000
houses within across the seven
councils on this scale they're getting
huge economies
of scale they've set up task force with
experts from the industry architects
and together they're um
it's bringing down the cost of the the
work
it's also
by keeping the um economy localizing the
supply chains in the local area it's
adding um
value and jobs to the local area
and then because i've mentioned this
before to go and i wonder if this is
something we could look at working with
our local councils
fine thank you
uh councillor huron
chairman yes thank you um
positive report very positive um i think
last time we had a
report this council probably two
meetings ago i was quite critical about
um
one thing but i was glad that it wasn't
in it was about the windfall sites and i
did give you a bit of a bad time didn't
i gavin but um and then two weeks later
you announced you were leaving so i hope
they weren't connected
but um no i'm pleased that that isn't
actually in this report i'm thrilled
that the climate change is sort of last
um finding fault and the fact that we've
declared a climate emergency that's
something that's more important than
anything else and with green issues
car parking well it keeps coming back um
i look to the future in ten years time
hopefully there'll be a
driverless people carry i come out to a
development pick up a dozen people and
take them to where they need to go and i
think umpteen car parking space is a bit
old hat anyway we do need to look to the
future
we cannot keep um there's more people we
need more houses but we cannot keep
clogging up everything with more and
more cars that cannot be the way forward
and it's a green disaster as well so um
that's my view we need to look in other
directions for that
thrilled allotments are making them a
comeback
allotments are fantastic i have one in
my village and it's a meeting place it's
everything if you've got an allotment
or a set of allotments oh goodness they
take the place of everything meeting um
you don't need a nightclub
um you could you you could take beer
they really are um
really are the future so um you know i i
know i'm speaking humorously because i
always do but there's serious issues
there that this does so much so i'm
thrilled that that's um
made the grade at last and i think maybe
instead of car parking we should be
concentrating on public transport port
which is oh god it's nearly died you
know it's serious if you live in a
semi-rural area or even um some of the
urban areas it it is dire there's hardly
a bus a day and
sometimes you can go somewhere and can't
get back um i know we're not responsible
for
i know we're not responsible for public
transport it is something we should be
trying to encourage
the only things i worry about jan and
gavin are the
level of anti-social behavior
and the effect that um
if this government enacts the right to
buy on housing association properties
that really will
impact on what we do here and would be a
terrible thing we're still suffering
from the thatcher area with the right to
buy on our council houses and that is
something i pray won't happen but um
more party or elbow a good report much
improved and looking forward and not
back as councillor busby says we must do
that so um thank you both thank you
council haram councillor simon barrett
thank you i i do find it rather rich
that councilman crore is espousing the
delights of extra building the first
time i met him was in his own village
where he was trying to stop development
in brampton but uh you know that's how
things change but uh
anyway so wanting some suggestions of
how we can build more houses well i'd
suggest that the councillor
uh
osborne looks at the standards of
passive houses have been put in the
document
as a it's too excessive
we do not require passive houses and
actually if you look at some ed's
has had passive houses and they're now
empty as a block of passive houses
absolutely empty can't be used doesn't
have the ventilation the tenants don't
understand how to use it it's a it's a
it's a standard too far we don't need it
building rigs as they are and they're
going up all the time provide perfectly
sound insulation for us to then put in
the things like the heat pumps etc and
the insulation is good so why we are
trying to go above that and have this
supreme standard which ultimately would
uh not enable us to deliver the numbers
that we require and our actual delivery
of houses 65 quite honestly has been
fantasy most of the time um because over
the last number of years we've done in
the in the tens
and we've done very few
so what i would suggest if you want a
positive approach counselor busby
because you obviously don't have any
suggestions because the fence that you
sit on would be not hold the weight
you probably need to look at reducing
that standard upping your numbers that's
how you're going to do it that's a
positive suggestion from this side
rather than the pettiness of council
macau
council maybe
and this will be the last
loss
thank you thank you madam chairman um
well i did have a question but you know
it might be nitpicking
but i might have a go
this is the first question and then i'll
make a couple of comments
um under page 31 under equality analysis
it says there are no equality
and diversity implications i would
disagree
and the monitoring officer i hope was
listening because i always disagree
sometime during the day
or the evening
if you look further up under
9.8
it says digital surveys
with a preferred method
however this may be because the
consultation exercise was digital
therefore those without digital access
were not represented so i think that
there is an issue there with equality
so i hope that will be addressed
um and the other point going on from
that is
okay
we're going to teach
80 year olds
90 year olds
i think well my dear husband did it use
a computer at the age of 80 but they
didn't certainly didn't at the age of
90. um
sorry is there a comment about my late
husband
no
thank you
but i would like to say
that
there may be
older persons who would like to use a
computer but do they realize that they
have to have broadband
and if
things are tight for them with the cost
of living who is going to pay for the
broadband connection so we haven't
actually looked at that and that may be
something
that the housing team needs to look at
in the future are we actually going to
put that automatically into our new
builds
so our tenants have it as part
of their um contract
so that's the first
now then the comments that i would like
to make
i'm sure councillor huron would be
delighted to know
that there is a system of centralized
cars
where you have one car in a village or
in a
cul-de-sac or whatever you'd like to
call it
and this car is loaned out to whoever
would like to use it so there's one car
for however many properties that may
help you to understand what is going on
and very lastly
i would like to comment about the
building of houses the new modern ones
because it was my homes for life that
actually turned things around
which is making those properties
suitable for those things that you do
not expect to happen to you in life
so a new build has
the slope up to the front door the wider
doorway
the internal wider doorways for
wheelchairs and i do remember the
opposition
was that from you gavin
i think it may well have been
that
the developers would never ever agree
so i challenged that and i said i would
go
with whoever whichever developers would
like to
to the building suppliers and negotiate
costs down for these particular items
really funny the next thing i knew it
was suddenly adopted and in the joint
local plan
around
sorry sorry
oh have i
well i think i've finished
so thank you homes for life for the way
to go thank you
so much
councilwood did you have a question a
comment a question because i'm trying to
end it now yeah i'm sorry it's just a
quick one man chairman um council
barrack uh
makes a valid point about um
not putting so much money into um
achieving standards at the expense of
numbers of housing but um he
there's no reference to passive house
standard in this document
so
we were
the aim the aim is epcc as a minimum
with uh a view to uh epca for the new
build but um
we don't i agree we don't want to build
passive house standard um for many
reasons but we just wanted to clarify
that
thank you council award
um
in in a moment councillor osborne i
think i'd like to thank all councillors
for their um very helpful and
constructive comments and debate here
i'd like to like now to return to
councillor osborne john osborne
to see if there's any comments that you
would like to add or sum up
thank you
yeah thank you madam chairman um first
of all on councillor mabry's comment
about our officer gavin
and there's no way gavin would ever not
take on a a suggestion from a councillor
so she's wrong there i'm afraid and i'm
putting the record right on that one on
the passive housing that's referred to
by councillor barrett and barristan
edmonds i think they were built some
time ago so obviously we've moved on a
lot with the materials that we use so
hopefully
when we build houses we will learn from
some of those mistakes from that one
that's been buried
so just to close thank you members for
your kind comments in most cases i think
this is an excellent document a great
deal of work has gone in to put in this
i know gavin's worked and his team have
worked extremely hard on this and it's
really difficult because it's a document
that changes day by day you know you put
a document in place and then there'll be
new legislation coming through or
there'll be more challenges coming
through and suddenly you have to revisit
the document again so it's been a really
hard challenging piece of work and i i'm
confident that this will deliver we're
already delivering we delivered that
presentation we had yesterday
demonstrated how much we've delivered
over the last 12 months we will continue
to deliver and this document will help
us in that way thank you madam jens
thank you councillor
agenda item number nine
bc 22 8 overview and security committee
annual report 2021 22.
i would like to invite council mclaren
to introduce her report which is for
noting
council mclaren
thank you
madam chairman it seems a long time
since the first
people welcomed you back
but at this point i would like to
welcome you back
to the council
on a personal note
[Music]
we missed you
as vice chair on overview and scrutiny
and uh so um you know i
am very pleased that you are well again
thank you
so much chairman and members i'm very
happy to present the annual report on
the work and recommendations of the baba
overview and scrutiny committee during
2021-2022
members will note that the required
statutory overview and scrutiny took
place of the required services and
functions
this year the shared legal partnership
came under scrutiny after a period of
some year's absence
in the current national climate of
uncertainty and financial upheaval a
common statement by the public
who are of course our residents are
saying someone someone should be helped
to work out
the overview and scrutiny committee
offers that opportunity for the public
to observe the council
public bodies
or for nine financially supported
agencies being held to account in
committee
it also provides members the chance to
contribute to the process by bringing to
committee areas and subjects that they
feel need scrutiny
the committee will then scope that
subject before recommending or not
that it be included in the work plan
as elected members we have a
responsibility to those who elected us
to prove that council services and
functions are fit for purpose
and that we have pursued all avenues to
ensure that
this i feel is the function of overview
and scrutiny
so thank you to all the members of the
baby
overview and scrutiny committee who
supported me over the past year
and i wish councillor hinson every
success as chairman in the coming year
i'm therefore madam chairman requesting
that members note this annual report
thank you
thank you
are there any questions for council
mclaren
councillor mayberry
um thank you madam chairman and first of
all
because it's altered and i don't know
the answer perhaps the monitoring
officer will let me know whether i have
to declare a couple of items
which is that you know i'm a director of
a citizen's advice
and also that i am chairman of a traffic
working party but i have no
voting rights on that do i need to
declare those
no so can i carry on with a question
right lovely thank you very much um so
my questions are
um
i'm trying to find mike page so
let's start with the shared legal
service which was reviewed in november
2021
there has been difficulties with with
this recently
um
with this service in particular
for my ward where something's been
outstanding for about six years
so i am asking if
or why actually i'll ask why
when
the shared legal service was reviewed
why was only on
monetary reasons and not actually on its
work schedule
and the um
what should i say the accountability of
their work
do you want all the questions in one
would you like all the questions
together
try that one thank you
we were
presented the overview scrutiny
committee requested if you remember a
member of the public
in a previous meeting that became
incorporate because members left very
quickly
it had been raised by a member of the
public
that he was concerned about the
efficacy of the shared legal service so
we
arranged a meeting to review that
in reviewing that we were presented
with a broad view and
about the activity and the costs
but your specific question i don't think
was answered
counselor maybe um thank you if i'm
making that perhaps i might suggest that
overview and scrutiny have a look at
that in the future
i'm sure i could i'm quite good at that
thank you
thank you there's two of us standing up
i'm sorry about that sorry i asked my
next question a monitoring officer wants
to make a comment
okay
thank you chad i just wanted to make a
point as a matter of procedure and also
as the assistant director with
responsibility for legal and that's just
to say that um overview and scrutiny
wouldn't look into a single issue as
your raising council may be so if
there's been an issue with the service
that's been received i'm more than happy
to
speak to you directly on that and
resolve that
council member thank you
thank you for that and i will send you
an individual
item but it's the whole
um what should i say it's it's the whole
workload that i think needs looking at
as well
okay thank you now my next question um
for overview scrutiny is and this is
under the joint parking strategy i was
really surprised to see hospital car
parks in that
well the only hospital car park that i
can think of in within baber
um would be the
sudbury health center
so could you
could you explain that please
when the the subject thank you
councillor mabry when the subject of
additional areas that may be considered
under the parking strategy was raised
we were in a joint
uh overview and scrutiny committee
and the
if i remember rightly i can't quite
remember but i think it was a
mid-suffolk counsellor that actually
raised about hospital car parks it was
not a valuable one
remembering that these are joint
overview and scrutiny reports and
therefore reflect both councils if
that's helpful
is that a short one because there are
other people who want to answer ask
questions
but
i've got lots of questions i've done my
homework
i'm not nitpicking i've done my homework
to actually add to that i think that is
an issue with overview and scrutiny when
there are so many joint meetings that we
can't actually um
get this um paired down to jess baber
but i was interested because i thought
is there a new hospital arriving in the
district that i knew nothing about which
would have been rather exciting
anyway um so i'm now going to move on to
um the review of local citizens advice
and i did have actually raised this
before
because on page 102
and it's talking about value added
and it says overview and scrutiny
committee recommended to cabinet that
the funding was increased to aid the
and it would be good if
members were actually informed by how
much when
if this was indexed linked and linked
and whether it was backdated because
this should have been done two years ago
thank you
thank you councillor madrid
well the issue about
increased funding the recommendation
actually came from me
was sudbury
and this was because
the
during the pandemic sudbury had actually
provided debt advice to ipswich um
citizens advice so that was a
recommendation for me
in terms of the index linking that has
been and i've been advised by councilman
mccror that had been brought up at
previous
um
overview scrutiny committees of of the
citizens advice
so that is already under consideration
at the moment
um the extra this will go to cabinet the
paper has has not been presented to
cabinet at the moment the cabinet to
make a decision
about the
extra funding for sudbury
sudbury has had this as a
token and a gesture under the cost of
living
paper
that sudbury will receive a 30
increase this year which is coming out
of the well-being
reserve fund
okay but it will be coming to cabinet
that very question about the
index linking and also cabinet has got
to decide whether they want to approve
an extra funding for the work that
sudbury is actually doing on behalf of
the whole district
thank you councillor melanie barrett
thank you
um i'd like to
ask um a general question about overland
scrutiny we know how important it is to
have strong scrutiny
to balance the the cabinet
um
do you think the calling process is
sufficient
when the option can be removed by
cabinet
and when it actually does happen
it has has no teeth whatsoever
um
do we need to beef it up
thank you councillor barrett it must it
must have been psychic
because i have actually
brought with me
the calling process
because i think
there is some misunderstanding
that came out of the last calling
meeting that the overview and scrutiny
committee actually
heard
when
the
request comes in for the calling
there is and it is heard there is a an
assumption
that there is a freedom of choice of the
outcome
and today i have got
the three options
that are placed
before the committee and they have to
make a decision
the first
option
that you can come as a result of the
scrutiny is refer the matter back to the
cabinet for reconsideration
together with the observations of the
overview and scrutiny committee
and cabinet will then take a final
decision but that decision
if it's referred on the first option you
cannot call it in again
which restricts your options
the section the second option is to seek
the advice of the monitoring officer as
to whether the decision is contrary to
or not wholly in accordance with the
policy framework or the budget and if
it's applicable refer the matter to full
council for a final decision
that is the second option
the third option
is that the decision be upheld and
implemented immediately
so
in the last calling which i know you're
referring to
the monitoring officer actually advised
us that option two
was not available
to the committee
so you had a choice in not being allowed
to call it in again
or the third choice was that the
decision be upheld and implemented
immediately and that was the choice that
the committee were left
to take
but i know you were not happy with the
outcome
thank you that was a clear answer
council mclaren have you got anything
else to add
and did you want to sum up
um well i just would like to thank
everybody
um it is a heart i i mean you will see
in my report uh chipmunk of german
that i was so surprised when i became
the chairman that there's a lot of hard
work
an amazing amount of hard work
undertaken by chairs and when you were a
vice chair undertaken by chairs and vice
chairs
and
lots of and democratic services work
really hard
and so
you know my thanks to everybody that
participated
um i believe in overview and scrutiny i
think we should be holding people to
account and i think our residents do
deserve that and expect that so thank
you very much
thank you council mclaren
that report was for noting only
item 10 bc 22 9 overview and scrutiny
committee work plan
[Music]
2022-23
i would like to invite councillor hinton
to introduce paper bc 22-9 which is for
noting
thank you madam chairman yes this paper
is for noting but i would just like to
draw
uh members attention to a couple of
points within within the
preamble for the report and the report
itself
this is a document that is evolving all
the time
it's not something that's set in tablets
of stone the the work plan changes
depending on what needs to be looked at
an example of that came through today
when the report from the
uh called the information bulletin from
the shared legal services performance
monitoring
has been delayed now until september
whereas it was going to be seen in july
so it's something that is constantly
evolving
within the the papers in front of you it
states in four point one the role of the
baby and scrutiny committee is defined
as having the key purposes of
scrutinizing the work of external
stakeholders and service providers
holding the cabinet to account
being the home of call-in
being the home of member call for action
i would like to add that
it should also read the scrutiny of the
way the council provides services to the
community and that's without restriction
so in other words all forms of services
that the council provides
overview and scrutiny has one chair and
meets every month
baber and mid-suffolk district councils
conduct joint committees on a regular
basis when similar topics have been
deemed suitable to be scrutinized
jointly
i think there's been a lot of these
joint meetings
where
the influence of mid-suffolk is perhaps
predominated
so i should be looking at that very very
carefully
otherwise as within appendix a
there are the
uh the proposed
topics so far
and i should be meeting with officers to
sit down and discuss a few other items
that i would like to bring forward into
the plan and see where we can put them
thank you and chairman thank you council
hinton are there any questions for
councillor hinton
yes i'm glad to see that council hidden
seas have got a grip of what ons is
about i'm really looking forward to
working with him and uh having some
positive outcomes and holding the
cabinet to account
so uh looking forward to working with
you john as uh if you're a record of how
you work on planning is anything go by
it should be very interesting
thank you in that case uh thank you very
much councillor hinton uh the report was
for noting only item 11 bc 2210
notice of key decision by general
exception
exempt from calling
taken by cabinet in accordance with part
two of the
constitution i would like to invite
council ward to introduce this report
which is for noting
thank you madam chairman
paper bc 2210 is a notice of a key
decision by general exception taken
recently by cabinet and which was exempt
from calling
the constitution requires that such
decisions are reported to council at the
next ordinary meeting
the details of the notice are provided
in appendix a
it refers the cabinet's decision to
approve an increase in the debt
threshold to enable the redevelopment of
the former hq site of course lane hadley
it explains the necessity to award the
contract before its expiry date and the
consequential impact on prices have been
a delay in this
the recommendation of 2.1 is to note
that this notice of a key decision by
general exception has been reported now
to council thank you chairman
thank you council report ward
that report was for noting only
point item 12 councillor appointments
are there any changes to placings
item 13
motions on notice
thanks chair none received
in that case
this i'll call an end to the meeting
the date of the next meeting is tuesday
19th of july 2022
at 5 30 p.m
it's been very nice seeing you all again
councillors thank you for a very good
meeting
you